Jenna Johnson and Bausch Markovski are
one step closer to tying the knot yep
time is winding down for our favorite
Dancing with the Stars duo to say I do
after Val popped the question in Venice
Italy back in June it is the fairy tale
that keeps unfolding before our eye it
really is and on Wednesday Jenna
revealed she finally found her dream
gown to marry Val's
[Music]
saying yes to the dress is so exciting I
feel like I know she posted this snap in
Kleinfeld bridal salon in new york
smiling from ear-to-ear captioned I said
yes to the dress
and get this her friend Peter Murgatroyd
who is of course married to vows brother
Maxim was seemingly a part of the big
day she commented on Jenna's post saying
it was the perfect day and if you didn't
know Kleinfelds is the shop featured on
TLC say yes to the dress so maybe we'll
see the magical moment when she found
her dress play out on TV I can't wait
literally hope that happen I know
putting it into the universe so you guys
not only has Jenna said yes to the dress
but we have a few other fun details
about the upcoming wedding here's
everything that we know so far
number one they do have the help of a
wedding planner and the big day is gonna
be super intimate take a look I should
be more stressed out but I'm not you're
not I have the superwoman of a mother
and we have an awesome wedding planner
and so yeah we're just gonna be checking
things off every day what type of
wedding do we envision because Dancing
with the Stars is basically our new
bachelor journey mean we're doing them
for intimate super intimate very
different no castle no no castle how
many people will say like intimate like
40 intimate aha no we have to put all of
our families in there yeah she's got
like 150 family members just her yeah
okay
and are you having like a food truck are
we having a city fancy formal yes it's
very
yeah very fancy but Susie but intimate
and boozy nothing that exclusive is the
word yeah okay they also already have
their date set more than a few familiar
faces on the guest list and babies on
the brain of guys I love this I know
take a look absolutely no I want I want
babies for sure I have eight beautiful
nieces and nephews and they are my life
gentle ones like seven kids that's not
true I want to I I come from a family of
eight and so I'm gonna go with two yeah
have you guys been talking about that
good oh yeah I already have all my names
picked out what are they we get you
married first
yeah I I'm very traditional in that
sense I want to get married first
so yeah you guys have a date set yes yes
is it this here is it next year wouldn't
you like to know I know you're and you
got the invite yeah
oh no yeah we haven't said I know that
you haven't set wedding invites out yet
can I marry you guys I'm scared that you
would like choke on to officiate your
wedding I'm considerate actually you are
Tom Bergeron I know Thomas Tom will be
there for sure I love him okay so I
cannot wait to see Jenna's dress and to
see the big day come to lay I know
weddings are always so fun of course we
will keep you updated with all the
latest so be sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time I'm a
coordinators cortes oh no I'm Katie
underscore kress and we'll see you next
time
[Music]